ANGE IN SENATE FILIBUSTER
RULES ALLOWING LEDGE HAITIAN
PROTECTING ABORTION RIGHTS.
DURING A NEWS CONFERENCE AT THE
NATO SUMMIT, HE SAID HE ISN'T
DOING OR SAYING ENOUGH TO
PROTECT ABORTION RIGHTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> YOUR VIEWS ON ABORTION HAVE
EVOLVED IN YOUR PUBLIC LIFE.
ARE YOU THE BEST MESSENGER TO
CARRY THIS FORWARD WHEN MANY
PROGRESSIVES WANT YOU TO DO?
>> YEAH, I AM.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
THAT MAKES ME THE BEST
MESSENGER.
I'M THE ONLY PRESIDENT THEY'VE
GOT.
>> I'M THE ONLY PRESIDENT THEY
LET'S BRING IN DAVID AXELROD.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT ANSWER,
I'M THE ONLY PRESIDENT THESE
PROGRESSIVES HAVE?
>> YEAH, LOOK, I HAVE SOME
SYMPATHY FOR HIM, BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY ISSUES LIKE THIS
WHERE THERE IS A LIMIT TO WHAT
HE CAN DO AT THE MOMENT.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE SAY LET'S DO
AWAY WITH THE FILIBUSTER AND HE
ENDORSED THAT TODAY.
BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE 50 VOTES TO
DO AWAY WITH THE FILIBUSTER AND
HE DOESN'T HAVE A MAGIC WANT
THAT CAN CREATE THAT OR MAKE 48
VOTES THE REQUIREMENT TO CHANGE
THE RULES.
AND SO -- BUT THERE IS THIS --
THERE IS A STRONG PASSION ABOUT
THIS ISSUE OUT THERE, AND PEOPLE
WANT HIM TO DO SOMETHING TO --
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THERE IS A
FRUSTRATION, I'M SURE, ON HIS
PART.
IT WAS NOT THE BEST ANSWER, I
WILL GIVE YOU THAT.
BUT I ALSO -- YOU KNOW, I FEEL
HIS PAIN, BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT
IT'S HIKE TO BE SITTING IN THESE
SITUATIONS AND BEING PUMMELLED
BY ELEMENTS OF YOUR OWN -- OF
YOUR OWN COMMUNITY.
>> TODAY, IN ADDITION TO
CRITICIZING THE COURT'S DECISION
TO GET RID OF ROE V. WADE, JOE
BIDEN CALLED FOR A CHANGE IN THE
SENATE RULES, THE FILIBUSTER
RULES.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN, AND IT ALSO
SEEMS TO ME, JUST AS AN OBSERVER
OF SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN AROUND
ENOUGH TO SEE THE HOUSE AND
SENATE FLIP CONTROL FROM
DEMOCRAT TO REPUBLICAN.
SHORTSIGHTED.
YOU CAN CHANGE THE RULES AND
PASS A CODIFY CASE OF ROE V.
WADE, ALTHOUGH THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH DEMOCRATIC CENTERS TO DO
THAT.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS TAKE THE SENATE AND
BAN ABORTION USING THE SAME
FILIBUSTER FREE RULES?
>> RIGHT.
AND I THINK THAT THAT HAS
GENERALLY BEEN HIS CONCERN.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THERE AREN'T THE VOTES NOW TO
CHANGE THE FILIBUSTER.
AND VERY LIKELY YOU'LL HAVE A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE COME -- UNLESS
SOMETHING UNFORESEEN HAPPENS.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE DIRECTION
WE'RE HEADED.
COULD HAVE A REPUBLICAN SENATE,
AS WELL.
SO, YOU KNOW, BUT I WILL SAY
THIS, THIS IS A -- THIS WILL BE
A MOTIVATOR, I SUSPECT, FOR
VOTERS OUT THERE TO VOTE FOR
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE PRO CHOICE
VOTES IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE IN THE FALL.
AND MAYBE THAT'S -- MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT HE WAS AIMING FOR.
MORE THAN ANYTHING, JAKE, HE
WANTED TO SHOW THAT HE WAS
MOVING FORWARD, THAT HE WAS
TAKING AFFIRMATIVE STEPS AND HE
WAS READY TO FIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HEAR QUITE A
BIT.
WILL HE FIGHT FOR THESE
INITIATIVES?
BUT HE'S ALSO SETTING UP A TEST,
AND, YOU KNOW, AT SOME POINT IF
THE RULE HASN'T CHANGED, IF THEY
HAVEN'T PASSED THE LEGISLATION,
IT WILL BE ONE MORE THING WHERE
PEOPLE SAY HE COULDN'T GET IT
DONE.
>> JOE MANCHIN AND SINEMA AREN'T
GOING TO GET IT DONE.
THERE ARE LOTS OF DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS VERY CONCERNED, LESS
PUBLICLY SO, ABOUT CHANGING THE
FILIBUSTER RULES FOR THE REASON
I EXPLAINED.
>> YES, YES.
AND JOE MANCHIN AND SINEMA
PROVIDE A COVER FOR THEM.
SO YEAH, THIS IS THE LOT THAT
BIDEN FINDS HIMSELF IN.
THERE IS THIS SENSE THAT THINGS
ARE OUT OF CONTROL AND HE'S NOT
IN COMMAND, AND THIS LENDS TO
THAT.
YOU KNOW, INFLATION IS -- NO ONE
PRESIDENT COULD CONTROL
INFLATION, BUT IT IS A -- IT'S A
GALE FORCE WIND RIGHT NOW
AFFECTING POLITICS.
VERY HARD TO, YOU KNOW, YOU
HEARD HIM ON GAS PRICES TODAY.
HE TALKS ABOUT THE GAS TAX
HOLIDAY, BUT HE'S NOT GOING TO
GET THAT, AND A LOT OF AMERICANS
THAT ARE SKEPTICAL THAT THAT
WOULD HELP.
SO THIS IS A VERY FRAUGHT
ENVIRONMENT FOR HIM RIGHT NOW.
>> IN FACT, JUST BECAUSE I WAS
JUST READING BARACK OBAMA'S
LATEST MEMOIR, PRESIDENT OBAMA
CREDITS OPPOSING THE GAS CREDIT
TAX HOLIDAY IN 2007, 2008, HE
SAYS -- BECAUSE McCAIN AND
HILLARY CLINTON WERE IN FAVOR OF
IT IN 2008.
AND HIS OPPOSITION HE THINK IS
THE REASON HE BEAT HER IN NORTH
CAROLINA AND TIED WITH HER IN
INDIANA AND BECAME THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, HE DID IT ON
HIS OWN.
THERE WASN'T A BIG CONSULTATION.
HE GOT ASKED ABOUT IT, AND HE
SAID WE TRIED THAT IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO 2000, AND NONE OF
THE MONEY GOT TO CONSUMERS, IT
WAS A FIG LEAF FOR POLITICIANS,
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS CHANGE
OUR ENERGY MIX.
HE GOT A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
VOTERS FOR TELLING THE TRUTH
ABOUT THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON
THOUGHT HE WAS CRAZY TO DO IT,
BUT IT DID CONTRIBUTE TO HIS
VICTORY IN 2008.
NOW, GAS PRICES WERE AT THE LOW
PRICE OF $4, NOT $5, BUT I
SUSPECT THERE IS A FAIR AMOUNT
OF SKEPTICISM TODAY, AS WELL.
>> EARLIER, WE SHOWED A POLL
THAT 85% OF THE PEOPLE OF UNITED
STATES THINK THE COUNTRY IS
HEADING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THAT POINTS TO DISASTER FOR
DEMOCRATS IN NOVEMBER.
>> IF YOU WERE LOOKING AT THE
CHART, YOU WOULD SAY THAT THE
VITALS ARE NOT GOOD.
THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING
IS 38%, CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS
DOWN.
THE NUMBER THAT YOU MENTIONED.
THE ONE THING THAT I DON'T KNOW
IS HOW THIS RULING BY THE
SUPREME COURT LAST WEEK IS GOING
TO AFFECT THINGS.
I'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY WHO HAVE BEEN DOING
FOCUS GROUPS AND POLL THING
WEEK.
IT DOES SEEM TO HAVE GALVANIZED
PEOPLE, AND NOT JUST ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, BUT CONCERNS ABOUT
REPUBLICANS AND EXTREMISM AND,
YOU KNOW, IF I WERE A REPUBLICAN
STRATEGIST, I WOULD BE A LITTLE
BIT WORRIED ABOUT THAT RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE POLITICAL
IMPACT IS GOING TO BE.
BUT THAT IS ONE COUNTERVAILING
FACT.
BUT ON T